si vous nous rejoignez on va jouer à la
décharge de l'action va passer en revue
toute l'actualité bien sûr de la
télévision et je rappelle et je peux
rappeler
bien sûr je rappelle que jean michel
maire n'a pas vu le film de sa ceinture
je le regarde et il a des électrodes
bouder également des électeurs de vous
poser des questions
l'équipe qui aura la bonne réponse bien
sûr fera gagner son champion et il lui
arrivera rien d'autre en revanche à
chaque fois on montera voilà sur les
chercher attention voici la première
question vous jouez bien sûr jean michel
vous jouez précédèrent célibat vous la
jouer avec eux les jouets cloud qui dit
à l'excédent khalidi non malades
d'alzheimer
merci mettez-vous à côté de votre ex a
je crois que ça marche paru kalamu
stallone avec à 6 6 et 14 par connerie
question hier dans wilde sur 1,6
qu'est-il arrivé à adria à des
participants de l'émission et qui n'a
rien de rien
allez vite oui il est dominant d'une
gorge il a fait une chute non mais c'est
bon alors merci ça c'est bon là
évidemment de commandes mais n'a touché
que j'espérais mais artères pur plaisir
[Rires]
on va regarder ça commence et non je
suis comme ça les regarde elle expliqué
c'est une image spectaculaire
un expert de l aventure lors de la
course de la finale voilà
adrien voulu descendre une crevasse et
il a fait une énorme chute regarder pour
moi ça fausse face à cette impasse sonne
corde
[Musique]
c'est un précédent
[Applaudissements]